pokemon one of the most successful
franchises in the history of video games
spawning a massively successful trading
card game and anime blockbuster films
toys clothing and so much more while the
main entries in this beloved series have
remained relatively faithful to their
tried and true formula they've still
seen new ideas that have helped them
influence future games and with that
let's take a look at my top 10 pokemon
games to play
in no particular order
i still remember to this day when i
first received my nintendo power with a
feature about pokemon and a mini comic
of the anime featuring ash meeting
pikachu before even playing the game
staring over the maps of the world of
pokemon i was hooked something about
this world just felt magical enter
pokemon red and blue a game invented by
satoshi tajiri thanks to his combined
interest in collecting bugs as a child
the link capability of game boys
allowing players to trade data and
wanting to be able to trade rare items
in dragon quest with his friends who'd
found rare items he hadn't the game
truly felt like it was made with love
and care with it having its own
fleshed-out universe
it was a world where people worked
together with pokemon who would help
them travel or destroy obstacles in the
way as well as fight and little nuances
like magikarp being the weakest joke of
a pokemon evolving into the intimidating
and strong gyrados were just the right
kind of quirks to bring the world to
life and while other pokemon games
iterated on pokemon and you could argue
to an extent made it better this game
set the stage for all of the pokemon
games to come and was so good at what it
did that even today the formula hasn't
strayed too far not only that but i
would argue one of the things about red
and blue i personally loved was that it
felt more feasible to become a true
pokemon master while the world of
pokemon is more vibrant than ever today
with 898 pokemon red and blue was a more
simple time with only 150 pokemon total
or 151 if you count mew or 152 if you
also count missing though and so long as
you traded with friends you could
actually collect every single pokemon in
this singular game even mew who you can
actually get thanks to a glitch this
will be contentious but for myself this
is something i actually really prefer
about red and blue and that feeling of
finally catching taurus my 150th pokemon
in the nightmare that was safari's own
is something i'll never forget
at his heart pokemon was a game about
collecting and for the avid collector
like myself that act alone made it worth
playing but what if you took that idea
and instead made it so you were
essentially collecting photos that's
what pokemon snap did the game put you
on a relatively linear track where you
were tasked with taking photos of the
various pokemon on your course your goal
was simple enough take photos of every
pokemon but the game made it so many of
them would only appear within certain
conditions you could trigger by
interacting with the course this created
a puzzle element to the game where you
were tasked with figuring out how to
make a pokemon act in more interesting
ways for better photos how to make
certain pokemon appear in the first
place and how to open up new paths that
would take you to new courses while the
game is unfortunately rather short it
goes to show how a simple concept
executed well can be far more fun than
many complex games the simple act of
solving puzzles and collecting photos of
the various cute and or cool pokemon in
clever ways was all the game needed to
be unique and memorable for an entire
generation who played games on the n64
and thanks to its popularity the game
finally saw a sequel released in 2021
which was similarly well received
love it or hate it 2016 was dominated by
the cultural force that was pokemon go
pokemon go was so huge it even dominated
mainstream news with countless stories
about people jaywalking or going to
restricted areas in order to catch
pokemon i even remember everyone at the
company i worked for at the time taking
extended
uh
coffee breaks in order to just walk
around and catch pokemon together or
become gym leaders while 2016's a
massive surge in pokemon go's success
was a bit of a flash in the pan as the
features were at that time pretty
limited a faithful core audience
remained and still remains to this day
with the game receiving several updates
that have completely enhanced the
experience whether this be quality of
life updates to make the general grind
more enjoyable or adding much wanted and
needed features like trading pokemon
sending friends gifts raid battles and
honestly a lot more while pokemon go was
very much initially its own one-off
thing it actually had an influence on
the main series pokemon let's go pikachu
and let's go eevee use the switch's
joy-con to catch pokemon in a similar
manner to how you catch pokemon in
pokemon go
released on game boy color pokemon gold
and silver brought back all of the
original pokemon from red and blue with
new enhanced looks while adding another
100 pokemon to the mix like red and blue
it was heavily reliant on trading
mechanics with gold and silver offering
slightly different collections to
encourage trainers to engage with their
community and friends but far from a
simple retreat pokemon gold and silver
introduced almost as many new mechanics
and features to the series as the
original those included a day night
cycle and weekly calendar so certain
pokemon would only appear at certain
times of day or on specific days of the
week pokemon gained the ability to hold
items that would restore health or
improve passive stats gold and silver
introduced new shiny pokemon extremely
rare variants with special coloring and
enhanced stats who for all of my years
playing pokemon i still haven't caught a
single one and i kind of secretly hate
the game for it gold and silver also
added not one but two new pokemon types
steel and dark to counter poison and
psychic pokemon respectively and they
introduced pokemon breeding which let
players pair their favorite monsters to
produce a new egg that would hatch into
pokemon that inherited stat bonuses from
its parents in addition to the eight
gyms in the jodo region gold and silver
actually took players back to the
original kanto setting of red and blue
for a second set of batches effectively
making the experience feel like two
games in one pokemon gold and silver are
still considered by many fans to be a
high water mark for this series like red
and blue gold and silver received an
enhanced version called pokemon crystal
while it was mostly similar it let
players pick their character's gender
for the first time add a new start of
battle animations and introduce the
battle tower for a gauntlet of pokemon
bouts
while there was pokemon stadium on the
n64 which was much beloved at the time
for allowing players to transfer and
battle their pokemon they collected from
red blue and yellow but now in 3d it was
essentially a glorified version of the
tournament and fighting features already
present in those games but now in 3d
however pokken tournament is the first
full-fledged 3d pokemon fighting game
with its own fighting game mechanics
this 3d fighter takes elements from
other fighting games with 3d free
roaming similar to powerstone but also
2d fighting incorporated as well like
any good fighting game the pokemon here
have their own unique move sets and
styles meaning you'll be able to find
one that works for you and a decent
balance of play types as well as depth
and while pokken tournament obviously
came out first i'm giving pokken
tournament dx the nod here as it
includes 5 more characters and a bunch
of new modes like 3v3 fighting all of
that means that this switch game is the
ultimate edition of pokken tournament
this might be a contested entry into the
list and i think it really depends on if
you like fighting games or not for my
part while the game's roots will always
be my favorite i think it's cool to see
the series branch out and do new things
with its wonderful world
the first entries on the 3ds pokemon x
and y were released in 2013 but remained
popular for a long time afterward due to
their sheer quality game balance and
wealth of features these entries were
the first to use a fully 3d presentation
and introduced the new fairy pokemon
type to help counterbalance the powerful
dragon type this generation also
introduced the new mega evolutions which
would let fully evolved pokemon
temporarily take on a special new form
and on top of all of that the games
still peppered in new content and
quality of life features like sky
battles horde battles and a
tamagotchi-like mode called pokemon on
me while they stuck to tradition like
many other pokemon games of its era x
and y were just well crafted enough that
fans didn't mind too much
the game boy this brought the third
generation of pokemon games ruby and
sapphire while at this point pokemon was
starting to see a similar formula
forming in a new truckload of monsters
to collect a new story and some new
features that's not necessarily a bad
thing when it's done well as ruby and
sapphire was released to the game boy
advance which was far more advanced than
the game boy color that meant the game
looked much more vibrant than silver and
gold on top of that pokemon ruby and
sapphire introduced double battles that
used two pokemon at a time these
versions brought about pokemon abilities
for further strategic customization
plus you could link up with up to four
players at a time instead of only two
the second nintendo 3ds pokemon entries
felt notably different from a lot of
their predecessors and this could be in
part because of the new tropical setting
based loosely on hawaii called alola the
environment and the look of the
characters was vastly different than
anything that came before and as someone
who absolutely loves hawaii and tropical
locations this honestly really clicked
with me while it might not matter for
everyone this shift in environment and
attitude was enough to really interest
me and bring me back into a series that
as much as i love it can at times feel
repetitive sun and moon included a few
new features as well like an increased
level of character customization it also
brought about new alolan forms of
pokemon regional variants of classic
faves that according to the lore evolve
differently depending on their
environment and if you don't love the
new version of executor i don't know
what to say because it is amazing this
idea of regional variance ended up being
carried forward to the subsequent sword
and shield
pokemon black and white's plot is
anything but black and white
i throw the dad jokes in when i can you
see while pokemon has always had a
kid-friendly vibe and a magical world at
the end of the day you're kinda
sorta using your pokemon for what are
essentially dog fights and black and
white finally address that issue the
main antagonist of the game is team
plasma whose leader n sees pokemon as
friends rather than tools and wants to
liberate them from their trainers who he
believes is oppressing them and while
the moral of the story ended up being
that pokemon like being used as tools
and fighting machines you know it was
still an interesting question for a
little bit pokemon black and white
included new features like a changing of
the seasons that would open up new areas
and impact the look of a couple of
pokemon themselves you could also take
part in triple battles with a team of
three pokemon allowing for some more
complex combat tactics like combination
moves most importantly the game featured
my boy ashwat or as i lovingly named him
bubble magoo although while duwatt is
pretty cool i'm not sure how i feel
about samurai
to be honest while i absolutely loved
pokemon blue and always enjoyed the
pokemon games since pokemon's fourth
generation in pokemon diamond and pearl
on the nintendo ds was the first one i
truly truly got absorbed into after blue
while the overall core gameplay changes
were somewhat minimal i really enjoyed
the game taking full advantage of the
nintendo ds's hardware notably diamond
and pearl had the first appearance of
the global tradestation or gts meaning
that by taking advantage of the ds's
wi-fi connection players from all over
the world could connect and trade their
pokemon and you would get plenty of
pokemon with super weird names that
weren't nearly as cool as bubble magoo
as pokemon diamond and pearl utilized
the nintendo ds hardware you had a
poketech on your bottom screen which was
essentially a smartwatch with various
applications you could earn throughout
the game like a friendship checker or
barry searcher i think outside of
nostalgia and what game you played first
for some your favorite pokemon game
might also be based around the pokemon
designs within the game and personally i
feel like gen 4 has some of the stronger
designs i'm one of those players who
gets super attached to my favorite
pokemon and as someone who likes weasels
and ferrets weasel and floatzel were
absolutely awesome also lest we forget
this was the pokemon that driftloon came
from drifloon who were known for and i
quote from sun and moon stories go that
it grabs the hands of small children and
drags them away to the afterlife it
dislikes heavy children if for some
reason its body bursts its soul spills
out with a screaming sound
so there you have the 10 best pokemon
games to play
according to myself i really believe
this is going to be deeply personal
based on your own experiences
preferences and nostalgia so let me know
what you think are the 10 best pokemon
games and honestly if you think i missed
something or sword and shield deserve to
spot feel free to tell me why i'm wrong
in the comments below and i'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
you